من خلال تحليل الخط الزمني لاستهداف
المستشفيات وخروجها تباعا عن الخدمه
لاحظنا ارتباطا طرديا بحركه النزوح من
شمال القطاع نحو الجنوب بحجم نزوح بلغ
مليون و900 الف نازح من شمال القطاع الى
جنوبه ما يشير الى منهجيه استهداف
المستشفيات كاستراتيجيه محوريه في مخطط
تفريغ السكان هنالك علاقه مباشره بين قصف
المستشفيات وتشريد النازحين لكن عدد
النازحين تجاوز مليو ونصف المليون انسان
هذا يعني ان كل هذا نتيجه الممارسات
الاسرائيليه في الواقع هناك مليون ونصف
المليون شخص تركوا مناطقهم وهم في حاله
ترحيل قسري مليون ونصف المليون اريد ان
اذكركم انه في النكبه تم ترحيل 700 الف في
عام كامل وها نحن نصل الى مليون ونصف
المليون في غضون ايام قليله هذا عنف لم
يسبق له مثيل
ه